Let's go to a color from the seven, seven,
four area code, potentially a local caller
who's calling today from seven, seven, four.
Oh, what does that mean?
That's you.
Oh, Hey, David, uh, sorry.
Both of the stream getting taken down last
night.
No.
Yeah, it was no good.
It's a shame.
But I just wanted to take a minute and expand
upon the segment from last week.
Uh, you had talked about, um, oh, you had
pointed out that at a recent rally in North
Carolina, Trump's line was actually a KKK
slogan.
The love it or leave it, uh, from that area.
And I recall the story from the Tom Hartman
program, um, from back in the 2016 election
cycle about how, I think it was his ex wife
who had pointed out that he carried a copy
of Hitler's speech book with him, and that
was like corroborated by
now.
Let me be clear, just because I don't want
to have any grammatical ambiguity.
Trump's ex wife pointed out that Trump did
that.
You're not saying Tom Hartmann's ex wife says
Tom's carrying this.
No, no, no, no.
Tom Bourbons.
Got It.
I'm not sure about that.
Yes.
So Trump's x had a head stated that he had
a copy of the new order, which was Hitler's
a or a compilation of Hitler's speeches.
Yeah, I think it was that he had the book
on his nightstand not carrying it around.
Yeah.
The only thing that causes me to question
that is I don't think Trump reads, so I don't,
it's hard for me to imagine about any books.
That's hard.
Maybe he had it on audio book too.
I don't know.
Yeah, very possible.
Um, but just thinking about that, I thought
it would be kind of interesting, like just
looking at the way that he kind of disseminates
his rhetoric.
Um,
that, just to extrapolate on that, like if
that were the case, it makes a lot of sense
because, and actually same cedar just had
a segment about this in which Trump was barking
back at al Sharpton for calling them out and
about the Baltimore tweets and he was saying
how he was the least racist person in the
world and that he's done more as an as two
and a half years as president.
Have been any president ever have before.
And I just, I literally shot like, it's not
out of my nose.
I was laughing so hard at the absurdity of
that statement.
Like, yeah, forget Abraham Lincoln.
Forget anybody who's done any abolition work.
You know,
what did they help that?
Now?
This is how the, that you're actually pointing
out exactly how the Trump is.
We'll defend it.
They'll say, guys, yeah, Trump's being symbolic.
He's not literally saying that he's done more
than Abraham Lincoln or Martin Luther King.
He's just saying in the modern era, given
what a president in 2019 can do, this guy's
done a lot.
And that's what you don't want to give him
credit for.
So they already know at any time that Trump
says something that's not literally true.
That's hyperbolic.
They say it's symbolism, but Trump's really
doing a good job.
Yeah.
Uh, and then that, uh, the same Cedar, uh,
segment from last night, he also pointed out
how a politico had a piece talking about how
this is this dog whistle.
A approach that he's taking is literally the
strategy that they had lined up that he was
going to attempt do you use for reelection?
That's right.
And that he's just actively seeking his next
Kaepernick.
And I thought that was quite a good take.
This is what I've been saying for weeks now.
This you, you can't win by exposing the things
Trump is saying because it's a strategy and
his followers like it.
So it's like, you know, it's what you're,
you're only going to convince them that he's
doing exactly what they want to see them doing.
That's not a strategy.
That's why we've got to win on turnout.
Absolutely.
Well, I think stigma call.
Okay.
Thanks.
I appreciate the call a great, we'll hope
to hear from you again.